Pierre connais ça. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dû à vos compétences. On vous
reçoit depuis à peu près une petite
année, peut-être 2 ans sur notre chaîne.
Euh, comment ça va ?
Bah, écoutez, ça va. Après la
présentation que vous avez fait, ma mère
va être contente.
Qui qui qui ça commence pas le Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succraintement ? Euh moi je suis d'abord
historien de formation.
J'insiste là-dessus parce que le temps
long est devenu une composante
importante de toutes les crises
internationales aujourd'hui. Bon, j'ai
enseigné pendant quelques années puis
après j'ai passer Lena et puis j'ai fait
une carrière dans la haute
administration en changeant de poste
tous les 5 ans à peu près. C'est le le
rythme au cours duquel je commence à
m'emmerder dans un poste. Donc
l'administration étant un employeur avec
de multiples fonctions. Et puis j'ai
passé les 20 dernières années de ma vie
professionnelle au ministère de la
défense à faire tout sauf de
l'administration.
Puis après, j'ai travaillé 10 ans dans
le privé et donc je continue à
travailler sur les sujets de politique
internationale mais aussi beaucoup sur
les questions de d'apparence, de
présentation, de comment dire de de
propagande, de communication et de et de
publicité politique quoi. Voilà,
je voudrais qu'on aborde pour la la
première question le le rapport qui a
été
fait par le ministère des affaires
étrangères, le ministère de la défense
concernant la propagande numérique.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire ?
Est-ce que vous avez assisté à la la
présentation par le ministre à
l'amphithéâtre Foche ?
Non, le ministre a fait un discours
classique sur le fait que les fake news
étaient un danger et cetera. Donc, on
lui avait écrit un discours qui n'a
absolument pas abordé le fond si ce
n'est cette thématique sur le thème
attention, vous êtes cerné par les fake
news. Non, ce qui est beaucoup plus
inquiétant, c'est la qualité de le du
rapport lui-même.
Je dois reconnaître que je l'ai pas lu.
Je l'ai pas lu pour une raison très
simple, c'est que j'ai lu les
conclusions et que j'ai assisté à la
présentation et que je suis parti avant
la fin.
Pourquoi ? Parce que ne traiter de fake
news, qui est la manière anglaise de
parler du c'est le terme américain qui
fait comme si c'était neuf, hein, ce
qu'on appelle la manipulation de
l'information dans les guerres, dans les
situations politiques et cetera.
Et donc qui c'est un un rapport qui
réussit à affirmer que seul la Chine et
la Russie font des fake news sans jamais
dire un mot sur le sur les États-Unis.
Mais finalement, je crois que je les
approuve parce que les fake news
comme quand si vous voulez parler de la
manipulation de l'information, c'est
quand même quelque chose qui suppose
qu'on ne connaisse pas l'auteur de la
manipulation. C'est-à-dire que la
l'information prend une crédibilité
parce qu'elle est bien présentée, parce
qu'elle était présentée par des moyens
de communication adéquate et parce que
finalement elle va prendre une
crédibilité de sa répétition, de sa
circulation. Or, écarter
George Bouche avec les armes de
destruction massive en Irak ou la
présentation de Coline Poel,
effectivement c'est pas des fux, c'est
du mensonge donc c'est autre chose dire
c'est pas la catégorie. Je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont exclu un sujet
aussi énorme que celui-là.
Le fait que je prends l'exemple de je
reprends votre exemple sur Coline Powell
et George Bouche
là le fait que c'est été propagé dans
les médias français à l'époque qu'est-ce
que c'est ?
Mais je crois qu'on était d'abord dans
un contexte politique où rappelez-vous
Chirak avait manifesté dès le début
qu'il ne refusait l'hypothèse de la
guerre. Donc les médias français ont été
enfin pour le peu que je m'en souvienne
he j'ai pas relu les articles mais j'ai
trouvé le s j'ai eu le sentiment qu'ils
étaient plutôt très distanciés de cette
présentation ce qui semble
extraordinaire et j'ai vu j'ai rencontré
par hasard Coline Pel après il a dit
qu'il avait été lui-même manipulé par
ses services c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait
autour de lui des gens qui voulaient
absolument qu'il l'apporte la preuve
avec son comment dire son aura d'ancien
chef d'état-major [raclement de gorge]
des armées de l'armée américaine que il
était il apportait lui la preuve
scientifique militaire et cetera, qu'il
y avait un danger. J'ai jamais su ce
qu'il y avait dans la petite fiole parce
queeffectivement s'il y avait du bassile
de l'entraquex et qu'il avait cassé la
petite fiole, il aurait tué toute
l'assemblée générale de l'ONU. Donc je
suppose que la petite fiole était vide.
Enfin, j'espère en tout cas qu'elle
l'était. [grognement]
Comment vous expliquez que qu'un rapport
coécrit entre le ministère des affaires
étrangères et le ministère de la défense
omette ce type d'information ?
[grognement]
[soupir][raclement de gorge]
Je sais pas, je je n'ai pas participé à
cette discussion. Euh ce qui est très
inquiétant, c'est deux choses.
D'abord, on narrive plus à repenser les
États-Unis. C'est-à-dire on l'a bien vu
avec George Bouge décidant
unilatéralement la guerre en Irak qui
entraînait quand même avec lui la moitié
de l'Europe. Bon, la façon dont traité
la France après la décision de Chirak de
pas y aller. Il y a eu un French bashing
qui était absolument délirant. On aurait
dû le URSS de Staline, vous savez, le
français c'était le couir. D'ailleurs,
regardez la guerre quand ils ont perdu
et cetera et cetera. Enfin, les French
Fri, faut que tout le monde connaît cet
épisode. Ça s'est traduit aussi dans le
cinéma. Et donc, on n'arrive plus à
penser les États-Unis. Et ça c'est une
espèce de paralysie de la pensée
stratégique française épisode que
moi-même j'ai vécu en 20032004 il y
avait on était sur le deuxème livre
blanc de la défense et à l'époque le
pilote de la de la chose avait créé une
espèce de groupe fantôme où il avait mis
d'anciens collaborateurs parce qu'il en
avait un peu marre de la comment dire de
la grand messe dans laquelle était tous
les hauts responsables du ministère de
la défense et des affaires étrangères
qui évidemment était dans un discours où
plus dans la norme que moi tu meurs
quoi.
Et dans ce le cadre de ce groupe
fantôme, je lui avais écrit un papier
qui justement tenait au fait que la les
États-Unis avaient déclenché une guerre
illégale évidente. Je avais dit "Mais y
a-t-il un risque américain ?" C'était la
thématique du papier et le risque ça
voulait dire qu'on ne le prenait pas que
comme d'un allié, mais ça voulait dire
qu'il fallait déjà prendre ses distances
entre politique extérieure, en moyen
économique, en moyen technologique et
cetera. [grognement]
Et il m'a dit "Vous avez raison,
malheureusement je peux pas l'écrire."
Donc vous avez là un épisode qui a il y
a 10 ans ou 15 ans, j'ai plus la date en
tête. Et ça c'est ça se retraduit encore
aujourd'hui par le fait que on va
s'aligner sur les Américains pour mettre
embarg la Russie et pas la et pas la
l'Arabie Saoudite par exemple.
C'est-à-dire on va dire attention la
Crimée vous rendez compte il a annexé la
Crimée, il a fait un référendum mais
c'est un référendum faussé et cetera. On
a fait la même chose au Comor en
annexant Mayotte.
C'est le référendum d'indépendance des
Comors. Mayotte est la seule île qui
vote contre l'indépendance et on dit "A
ben non, alors si Mayotte a voté pour le
rattachement à la France, Mayotte est
française." Bon, ce qui était exactement
le même scénario que la Crimée quoi.
Donc si vous voulez, il y a une absence
totale de mémoire du temps long, je
reviens là-dessus chez les chez nos
élites et ça tient probablement à la
formation de science P. C'est-à-dire
qu'on comme l'histoire commence en 1830.
Le fait [raclement de gorge] qu'on est
formé, si vous voulez, dans une espèce
de mode de pensée que j'ai souvent
constaté, c'est-à-dire que euh il faut
la validation de la hiérarchie. Donc la
hiérarchie est là pour euh rappeler à
l'ordre et puis le fait que on a souvent
des gens qui ne connaissent pas le
monde, c'est-à-dire des gens qui
arrivent directement à des postes de
responsabilité ou à des fonctions
d'écriture mais qui ne connaissent pas
le monde. Quand j'entends connaître le
monde, ça veut dire ne pas être allé
simplement dans la capitale pour être
avoir des entretiens officiels. C'est
avoir vu comment fonctionne un pays,
avoir fait le éventuellement la route,
avoir des amis qui soient de ce pays qui
puissent leur donner des sensibilités.
Ça c'est un problème grave. Donc on a
reconstitué en fait la guerre fraude.
C'est rassurant parce que finalement la
Russie et la Chine sont les puissances
du mal qui ment tout le temps. Mais avec
des savoir-fa c'estàd maintenant
évidemment avec les moyens d'internet.
La seule chose qui a change par rapport
à l'habitude de la manipulation de
l'information [grognement]
c'est que à l'époque si vous voulez de
l'entre de guerre ou à l'époque de la de
la guerre froide on avait pas
l'extraordinaire capacité de diffusion
que constitue internet. Donc euh tout à
coup, ça a changé le paysage. Mais je
crois qu'on est comme souvent avec un
phénomène nouveau, c'est-à-dire on va
d'un seul coup rendre totalement
responsable comme si ça bouleverait
tout. Rappelez-vous quand l'appar la
télévision apparaît, il faut l'interdire
aux enfants parce que la télévision est
un moyen de perdition. Pareil pour la
radio, pareil pour le cinéma et cetera.
Donc vous voyez, on est dans cette phase
là. Ce qui est regrettable, c'est que
des instituts en fonction officielle qui
avaient quand même vocation de réfléchir
un peu ne citent pas une seule fois dans
le rapport ces deux épisodes dramatiques
américains qui ont fait perdre toute
crédibilité aux démocraties. Ça, on se
rend pas compte. Mais comment
voulez-vous dans le monde arabe faire
croire que effectivement les Américains
sont encore le pays de la vérité, de la
démocratie et cetera ? Ils ont le
sentiment que [souffle coupé]
c'est les fake news, c'est la version
clean si vous voulez propre sur soi de
la théorie du complot.
théorie du complot et on imagine c'est
la CIA qui a organisé les du 11
septembre les fait nous c'est non non
non attention c'est beaucoup plus
discret que ça mais fondamentalement il
y a des puissances du mal qui tient les
ficelles derrière nous quand vous avez
des [raclement de gorge] quand vous avez
des Américains qui financent des ONG
pour faire foire les révolutions
oranges, on dit c'est normal c'est des
ONG bon quand les Russes se mettent à
contrôler les ONG étrangères ils font
rien de plus que ce que feraient les
Américains s'il y avait des ONG ou
éventuellement des Russes qui venaient
se venaier de leurs sélections.
Pensez-vous, c'est pas possible ces
choses-là ?
Dans dans dans ce fameux rapport, on
aborde [raclement de gorge] des
mouvements de de satellites militaires
russe autour de nos propres satellites.
Euh c'est sorti au même moment que ce
rapport là. Est-ce qu'il y a une
J'ai pas d'opinion sur le sujet, c'est
possible que techniquement de façon
qu'il y ait de l'espionnage dans le
spatial, ça c'est une c'est une
évidence. les transmissions de données
on son peuvent pas toujours être toutes
cryptées. Ça veut dire que la masse
d'informations ouvertes qui circule sur
le sur les réseaux spatiaux sont de
toute façon des sources d'information
gigantesques. Le reste, je suppose que
les communications sont cryptées de
manière suffisamment solide pour que ce
soit pas simplement la nuée de satellite
qui tourne autour qui permettent de
décrypter. Que ce soit éventuellement
une posture de destruction des
satellites en cas de conflit, ça c'est
possible. Mais je crois que tout le
monde est à peu près d'accord sur le
fait que on a tous signé un accord de
démilitarisation de l'espace. Donc vous
voyez comment il est respecté.
Je j'ouvre une petite parenthèse avant
de revenir sur nos sujets. L'affaire
scripal, vous avez une petite idée ?
Non, j'ai pas d'idée.
Pas penché sur le sujet.
J'ai un alibi. Non, j'étais ici moi.
C'était pas vous ?
Non, c'est pas moi.
Vous vous visitez pas la la flèche de la
cathédrale de Salzbury ?
Non, non, j'ai pas de j'ai j'ai rien à
dire sur le sujet. J'ai pas suivi.
Une petite dernière sur le sur ce
rapport. Ça a été présenté en grande
pompe à l'école de guerre anciennement
collège interarmée de défense. Est-ce
qu'il y a une radicalisation de notre
armée ? Est-ce que notre armée a voulu
faire plaisir à notre chef d'étatmajor
des armées Emmanuel Macron ?
Je sais pas s'il veut y voir une espèce
d'ambition.
Est-ce que c'était pour légitim des
futurs crédits ? Est-ce que c'était des
des futurs crédits ?
C'était légitimer leur poste ? C'était
quoi ? Non, d'abord euh il faut
comprendre que la toutes les
administrations sont des machines à
produire des rapports, hein.
C'est-à-dire que un rapport le son
avenir personne ne le prédit.
Donc celui-là va aller peut-être
rejoindre d'autres rapports sur le
danger, le risque. Par exemple, les
rayonnages qu'on a vidé depuis, il était
plein de d'études sur le RSS en 2025 par
exemple. Bon, donc si vous voulez, il y
a toute une fonction du rapport qui est
une espèce de mise en forme si vous
voulez de ce qu'on croit être la
réalité. Ça c'est une chose importante.
La deuxième c'est qu'ils ont
effectivement fait une présentation à
l'amphi qui est le grand ami de l'école
militaire 600 places. Ils avaient
rabattu tous les militaires en formation
à la à l'école militaire. Donc tous les
rangés étaient remplis. Le ministre a
fait un discours de présentation pour
expliquer la dangérosité des fake news.
Mais je pense que le type qui lui a
écrit le discours est à peu près le même
que ceux qui ont fait le rapport.
C'est-à-dire que c'est présenté comme
une espèce de comment dire de de
nouvelles méthodes de guerre. euh
influente et indirecte
mais sans que ça apporte quoi que ce
soit sur le sujet. C'estàd si on
découvrait aujourd'hui une manière de
tester de l'objectivité des
informations, on aurait fait un immense
progrès. Mais là, on est dans l'espèce
de dans une espèce de diabolisation où
on dit on va alors une des propositions
typiques des
rapports administratifs en général ça se
termine par il faut affiner les
concepts, il faut améliorer la
coordination et il faut approfondir la
réflexion. Ça c'est une conclusion
générique. Quel que soit le rapport, ça
peut toujours marcher. Donc là en
l'occurrence, ils veulent créer une
structure qui s'occuperait des fake
news, qui serait évidemment peuplé de
non pas de journaliste, mais qui serait
peuplé d'administratif. Donc je laisse
tomber quoi.
On passe aux sanctions.
Allez,
les sanctions, c'est quoi à notre époque
? Ça sert à quoi et est-ce que c'est
efficace ?
Bon, les sanctions, ça une inventure
assez ancienne.
Je remonte pas l'antiquité. En général,
ça fait bien de citer un truc dans
l'antiquité, mais je veux pas en parler.
Si voilà, en gros, on a testé avant
guerre la politique des sanctions.
Rappelez-vous, on a t testé par exemple
quand le Japon envahit la Chine, les
Américains ont mis des sanctions et
cetera. Mais là, je vais parler plutôt
des sanctions qui ont suivi notamment
qui ont suivi le
le l'écroulement du RSS. Pourquoi ?
Parce que d'abord à l'époque les
sanctions, c'était la guerre froide,
donc il était même pas question de
sanction. On se vendait rien et donc ou
en tout cas on se vendait si peu de
choses et en tout cas pas du matériel
sensible. Donc les sanctions n'avaient
pas de raison d'être spécialement
importantes. Par contre, après 91, on
est rentré dans une espèce d'époque des
sanctions. C'est-à-dire qu'à ce
moment-là, la communauté internationale
a commencé à voter des systèmes de
sanction. En particulier parce que 91,
c'est la guerre du golf. C'est-à-dire
qu'on va rentrer tout de suite avec le
la défaite de Saddam Hussein et avec
l'application d'un des plans d'embargo
les plus odieux et les plus inhumains
qu'on a inventé. c'était le premier
peut-être c'est peut-être pour ça qui va
donc imposer à l'Irak un plan de
sanction de devant aboutir
démantellement de ses programmes d'armes
de destruction massive. Alors, il y
avait armes de destruction massive, ça
c'est une évidence. Je l'insiste parce
que la deuxième fois qu'il nous ressorte
le coup
avec fils bouchef si vous voulez, c'est
c'était du mensonge absolu. Mais donc on
se rend compte quand même, première
chose que le traité de non prolifération
avec ses moyens de vérification dans sa
version de l'époque était insuffisante.
C'est-à-dire que personne n'avait vu
l'importance et l'avancée des programmes
d'armes de destruction massive [soupir]
de nucléaire.
Par contre, pour ces armes chimiques, on
le savait très bien pour plusieurs
raisons. D'abord parce que c'est des
Américains qui avaient fourni les
précurseurs. Vous savez, c'est le
précurseur, c'est celui qui va
déclencher le le mélange chimique qui va
tuer des populations. Donc à l'abja, il
y avait des précurseurs américains.
[grognement]
Le nucléaire, nous on le connaissait un
peu puisque c'est nous
pardon.
C'était à nous. Non, c'est pas à nous
quand même. Nous, on avait vendu aux
Irak, c'était quand même pas Non, non,
on avait pas tout vendu. Et après, ils
avaient leurs propres compétences, c'est
vrai. Mais on savait on savait qu'il y
avait eu un programme d'ailleurs, il
avait été détruit par cette opération
militaire qu'avaient fait les Isra
euh et puis pour le bactériologique,
c'est très difficile de détecter le
bactériologique parce que par principe
un hôpital, c'est un un foyer
bactériologique.
Donc il y a eu un programme de
démantellement complet avec des missions
d'inspection qui étaient extrêmement
importantes, intrusives, complexes et
cetera.
C'est vrai que les irakiens avaient un
certain savoir-faire, c'est-à-dire qu'on
avait constaté quand même que à chaque
fois que la mission arrivait quelque
part, il y avait un gros camion qui
partait chargé d'archive et on l'a en
particulier su parce que donc cette
technique d'évitement qu'avait le l'Irak
sous embargo,
on en avait su l'ampleur parce que le
gendre de Saddam Hussein s'était sauvé.
Il était parti en Jordanie parce que il
croyait que comme les occidentaux
voulaient la la tête de son beau-père,
le successeur ce serait lui. Bon, je
sais pas comment Saddam Hussein a réussi
à le convaincre de rentrer, mais
toujours est-il qu'il est rentré en
laissant derrière lui tout un camion qui
était chargé d'archives iakiennes
justement sur toutes ces archives qui
avaient été dissimulées. En tout cas, sa
tête valait pas assez pour que les
occidentaux le retiennent. Il rentre en
Irak et puis là, il y a une scène
shakespearienne, c'est-à-dire que Saddam
Hussein oblige ses enfants à tuer leur
père pour montrer qu'il y a leur
fidélité au régime. Bon, je laisse ça de
côté. C'est un jour pour écrire un
roman. Donc après ça, il y a 10 ans, non
seulement d'embargo, mais de mission
d'intrusion euh qui vont volontairement
aller sur tous les sites, démanteler
tous les sites nucléaires et cetera.
Alors, le nucléaire ne peut pas se
cacher, ne peut pas se dissimuler parce
que c'est des installations lourdes,
c'est des installations qui sont
visibles sur internet, c'est des
installations où il y a des systèmes de
chauffage où quand on fait de la photo
infrarouge, on voit si une centrale
c'est une centrale électrique ou si
c'est une centrale nucléaire et cetera.
Donc
[raclement de gorge]
HBX qui était le principal
homme chargé de l' vérification du
programme nucléaire était absolument
catégorique. Le programme était
démantelé.
Deuxième les autres larmes chimiques et
cetera ça été un peu plus long enfin en
gros c'est l'embargo décidé par les
Nations Unies contre l'Irak a été le
plus absolu et le plus total qu'on n
jamais appliqué nulle part où que ce
soit.
C'est-à-dire que pour donner des
exemples,
il y avait une mission chargée de
valider toute importation irakienne et
on imp on on excluait les mines de
crayon pour les écoliers parce que ça
contient du graphite, c'est un
ralentisseur de la réaction nucléaire.
On interdisait les médicaments parce que
les médicaments ça peut donner lieu à du
comment dire des essais de pour des
armes bactériologiques. Enfin, c'était
devenu un délire absolu. Ça a été une
des catastrophes humanitaires les plus
effroyables de la deuxème moitié du 20e
siècle. C'est-à-dire qu'on estime,
encore une fois ces chiffres sont
difficiles à vérifier, mais on estime
qu'il y a à peu près 500000 enfants qui
sont morts pendant cette période de
l'embargo, qui sont morts de la rouge de
la dysenterie, de la fièvre, de choses
qui sont d'une banalité absolue parce
que la mission de vérification était
essentiellement le les vétaux ont été
essentiellement anglais américains et
ces vétent surtout et n'importe quoi et
indiscutable. Donc ça a été une espèce
de de comment dire de d'effroyable
tragédie.
Et ça a été tellement révoltant que
finalement il a fallu adopter une autre
version du de politique d'embargo. Ça a
été le
le programme qu'on a appelé pétrole
contre nourriture. C'est-à-dire
on autorisait les RAC à exporter plus de
pétrole pour se payer de la nourriture.
C'està-dire le contrôle étant
effectivement destiné à vérifier que
c'était bien de la nourriture qui était
importée ou que c'était bien des
médicaments et cetera et cetera.
Donc ce programme était censé alléger
les sanctions et en fait plusieurs
remarques méritent d'être faites sur
cette deuxième époque, c'est que
d'abord des dans l'embargot évidemment
ça fragilise la population, évidemment
ça fait augmenter le coût des matières
le coût des den réalimentaires,
évidemment ça fait souffrir la
population et cetera mais surtout ça
installe la corruption et le trafic
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a aucun embargo qui
soit vérifiable à 100 % et qui soit
applicable à 100 %. Je prends un
exemple. L'Iran à peu près a à peu près
15 pays frontaliers et 2800 km de
frontière si je ne m'abuse. Donc
j'arrête là l'exemple il suffit. Ça veut
dire que des tas de pays qui sont pas
sous contrôle américain peuvent très
bien continuer à trafiquer avec l'Iran.
Donc l'embargo est une espèce de
mythologie qu'on adopte en disant ça ça
va être très dur, on va les faire plier.
Tragédie humanitaire et puis corruption.
C'est-à-dire que quand on a fait pétrole
contre nourriture,
les on s'est aperçu que une alors une
partie de pratiquement un peu moins de
50 % de cet argent plus en plus était
destiné à réparer les dégâts du Kuwait,
à payer les agents auusiens et puis je
me souviens plus, il y a une troisème
fonction. tout le reste, c'estàd moins
de un peu près 54 % étaient destinés à à
acheter effectivement des produits. Donc
vous voyez qu'il y a des gens qui vivent
sur l'embargo. Important à savoir.
Euh on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait de la
corruption parce que justement un beau
jours euh notamment après l'invasion de
l'Irak, on a découvert que toutes les
les comment dire les les mandats si vous
voulez qu'on envoyait à différentes
personnes, y compris en France, y
compris aux États-Unis, y compris en
Russie et cetera, pour que il y ait des
moyens de contournement de ce fameux
embargo. Donc l'embargo fait de la
corruption dans le pays
puisqueévidemment c'est ceux qui font du
trafic avec la en contournant l'embargo
qui gagne le plus de pognons. On l'a
connu pendant l'occupation. Et puis
évidemment les siraquiens avaient un
certain savoir-faire pour corrompre des
personnalités étrangères qui allaient
ensuite tenir un discours sur le thème
enfin ses pauvres gens il souffrent et
cetera. Alors que j'en avaient rien à
faire. Il y avait Charles Charles
Pasquis parmi les bénéficiaires de
de ces de ces libéralités iakiennes et
puis il y a d'autres normes. Enfin bon
le procès mériterait en soi une
démonstration. Donc ça installe de la
corruption et puis évidemment ça délite
complètement l'autorité de l'État
puisque finalement chacun sa chacun pour
soi cet état qui est incapable de vous
protéger et cetera. Donc le programme
pétrole contre nourriture a été aussi
une espèce d'allég mais en même temps
une espèce d'échec ou en tout cas dont
les conclusions n'ont jamais été tirées
comme tel parce que le décideur de
l'embargo ne s'intéresse jamais à
l'effet à l'effet exact de son embargo.
Il va sortir de l'assemblée générale de
l'ONU content parce que nous avons
aggravé les sanctions.
Donc le cette idée de généralité de
l'embargo, l'exemple irakien était
particulièrement grave et donc il a
[grognement] il a évidemment amené des
réflexions très critiques sur
l'utilisation de cette de cette arme. Et
comme aujourd'hui on recommence à
nouveau avec Trump à vouloir un embargo
total sur l'Iran
et la Russie, non ? Les sanctions sur la
Russie.
Ah oui, alors bon, il y a effectivement
les sanctions sur la Russie. Bon, donc
première remarque, les sanctions sont
pas destinées à punir le pays qui est
dans un état d'illégalité. Il est
destiné à punir le pays que la consensus
occidental décide comme de punir. Encore
une fois, c'est parce que on n' pas puni
les États-Unis pour avoir envahi l'Irak.
Personne n'a jamais pensé qu'on allait
mettre un embargo sur les États-Unis. Il
n'y a force de faire passer George
Bouche à la Cour pénale internationale.
Donc soyons entre gens sérieux. Donc la
Russie a fait ce qu'on a fait à Mayotte,
c'est-à-dire a fait la l'annexion de la
Crimée dont tout le monde reconnaît
qu'elle était peuplée à 90 % de Russe.
Euh le que donc on a fait Mayotte, c'est
dire Mayotte au monde d'indépendance des
des comorts. Mayotte est la seule île à
voter pour rester dans la rattaché à la
France. Et donc on dit "Ah bah si
Mayotte veut rester française, Mayotte
va rester française" et donc de encore
aujourd'hui les comors se plaignent de
cette de cette de ce comportement. Effet
pervers si vous voulez de Mayotte, c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la plus grosse maternité
française est à Mayotte.
C'estàd que les Comoriens traversent le
D3 pour venir accoucher à Mayotte pour
que les enfants soient français.
Plus grande porte de l'immigration
européenne.
C'est la plus grande porte de la
naissance des enfants. C'estàd c'est une
c'est la plus grosse maternité de
maternité de France. Voilà. Donc donc on
est sur quelque chose où si vous voulez
on sanctionne mais de manière totalement
aléatoire. jamais d'idée de sanction
contre les Israël pour les territoires
occupés. Quand il y a eu même une
campagne d'initiative de boycotte sur
uniquement sur les produits produit dans
les territoires par des colonies dans
les territoires occupés, le gouvernement
français s'y est opposé. Donc on est sur
encore une fois sur une politique de
sanction qui est on vous dit qu'il y a
le méchant à sanctionner.
Bon euh
une parenthèse, quand les États-Unis euh
disent qu'ils vont poursuivre
le tribunal de la s'ils inculpent des
ressortissants américains ou qu'ils
feront tout pour [grognement]
Alors le je reviendrai sur la Cour
pénale internationale puisque
l'historique est assez rigolo. Donc
quand il y a le
quand il y a le la guerre en Youoslavie,
donc il y a ces massacres effroyables
1000 km de Paris, enfin c'est quelque
chose d'assez scandaleux les bordels
organisés avec les femmes croates
violées en quantité et cetera. Bon ou
les femmes bosniaques moi euh sur une
idée venue de l'administration
américaine de Clinton, on décide de
créer une cour pénale internationale
permanente puisqueavant il y avait eu
des cours spécialisées pour le Rwanda et
cetera pour des choses comme ça mais là
on décide une cour pénale installée
définitivement
avec un traité consign à Rome et donc
qui rentre en effet à partir du moment
où je sais plus de tiers des États le
valide. Bon, ceux qui font défaut, c'est
les Américains, exactement comme s'était
passé le scénario de la SDN après la
guerre de 141. C'estàd il y a une
initiative, on attention nous on s on se
met pas dedans. Le principal argument
des Américains pour refuser le Congrès
pour refuser la
la validation de du traité de Rome,
c'est de dire jamais
[raclement de gorge] on acceptera qu'un
homme politique ou qu'un soldat
américain soit jugé par une cour pénale
internationale.
Donc c'est le système est créé mais il
est il est fissuré par son par son père
fondateur. Évidemment la Chine et la
Russie disent "Mais attendez, nous on
peut pas y aller si les Amériques sont
pas et" et puis Israël dit "Mais nous ça
nous recorde pas" et cetera. Donc, on a
été nous européens plus un certain
nombre d'autres pays les seuls à
soutenir le projet. Il faut pas
s'étonner qu'évidemment il y a surtout
des chefs d'état africains qui été
sanctionnés par la Cour pénale
internationale hein. Bon non donc le
aujourd'hui on est passé à une étape
supérieure où vous avez l'équipe de
Bouche qui est quand même très créative
dans le plan de la connerie qui vient de
dire que ils allaient carrément saisir
les biens de des juges de la Cour pénale
internationale. Je crois que c'est
Bolton qui a dit ça. Si jamais ils
allaient plus loin dans Donc le je
reviens sur la sur la question des
embarg
révélé une de manière très dramatique
les conséquences indirectes des
embargots. Alors j'ai regardé
aujourd'hui l'Union européenne a à peu
près 23 pays sous embargot dont certains
en fonction des anciens gouvernements he
la Tunisie, l'Égypte et cetera. Bon mais
enfin il faut savoir qu'il y a plein
d'embargot. Ça veut dire que pour des
entreprises qui veulent exporter, il
faut qu'elles aillent vite se renseigner
pour savoir. Évidemment, c'est surtout
le matériel de guerre ou les matériels
dérivés à double usage qui sont visés,
mais enfin, il reste que faut faire
attention.
Euh donc se sont révélés c'est révélé à
cette occasionlà le pouvoir extritorial
que l'administration que la justice
américaine s'accorde. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui si un contrat
international est signé en dollar, si
une partie du contrat était signé sur le
territoire américain, la justice
américaine est compétente pour juger de
du caractère illégal du contrat que ça
peut être violation d'un embargo ou acte
de corruption. Toute la mécanique s'est
mise en place après 97 quand on a voté
la convention au CDE sur le contre la
corruption sur les marchés étrangers.
Donc les Américains ont voté une loi
interne qui s'appelle le Foreign
Corruption Act qui justement donne ses
compétences au à la justice américaine
qui s'est progressivement élargi
aujourd'hui donc on a eu de magnifiques
cours réalisés par les Américains
notamment Alstom qui a été accusé par la
justice américaine d'avoir inversé des
commissions. Donc l'action a baissé donc
le général électrique a racheté le somum
et puis les actions se sont arrêtées.
Parfois ça tombe aussi financièrement he
je crois que j'avais regardé que la
justice américaine avait encaissé comme
ça 40 milliards de dollars d'entreprise
européenne qui avait été condamné dans
ces 4 c dernières années. Donc on est
sur un système qui aujourd'hui il y a un
embargo, il y a un pouvoir qui gère
l'embargo. Il y a des Européens qui
ferment leur gueule et donc on a
aujourd'hui une carte du monde qui
traduit toute la relation internationale
c'est-à-dire on a un usage de l'embargo
qui est un usage différencié.
Euh il y a les bons, il y a pas les
méchants. Bon, l'Iran est un méchant,
l'Arabie Saoudite est un bon. Il y a pas
d'embargo sur l'Arabie Saoudite. Cela
dit, cela dit, quand on a réussi à
mettre sous embargo la Russie, le
premier producteur mondial de pétrole,
on va mettre l'Iran ensuite. Je veux
dire, on se met complètement entre les
mains de l'Arabie Saoudite.
Quand vous dites les Européens ferment
leur gueule, c'est les politiques
européennes.
Mais je crois qu'en fait l'Europe a pris
conscience de son extraordinaire
fragilité. C'est-à-dire que d'abord, on
se rend compte que l'Europe est
fissurée, hein, par des tas de problèmes
sur lesquels je reviendrai pas, mais
l'euro n'a pas réussi à se constituer
comme monnaie alternative du dollar dans
les échanges internationals. Donc ça
c'est quand même un problème grave. tout
le marché pétrolien encore labellisé en
dollar. Donc cette compétence qu'a
justice américaine de juger d'un
contrat, même s'il s'est passé à l'autre
bout de la planète mais qu'il a été en
dollar donc lui permet de finalement
contrôler l'essentiel des activités
mondiales.
C'est quand même c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'on a qu'on avait pas
jusque-là. Et évidemment dans le cadre
de l'embargo, des entre des entreprises
qui ont violé des embargots américains
mais pas européens pourraient être
condamnés par le droit américain et même
si elles ont si l'Europe n'a pas validé.
L'exemple de Cuba est assez est assez
significatif. Je crois même une fois ils
avaient ils avaient voulu mener une
action contre le chanteur Rikouer parce
qu'il avait fait un enregistrement à
Cuba. Le chanteur américain. Bon ça
s'est arrêté là mais enfin et puis il
avait des des Hvanes dans sa valise je
crois. Donc on est sur quelque chose qui
est totalement maladif mais surtout avec
des pouvoirs totalement exorbitants.
Pour ne pas être totalement quand même
unilatéral, il faut aussi reconnaître
que c'est cette fonction exterritorielle
de la justice américaine qui a permis de
mettre en examen toutes les grandes
fédérations internationales sportives
parce que comme ce sont des associations
de droits suisses mais qui ne reçoivent
aucune subvention de la Suisse, elles ne
sont sous le contrôle de personne. Et
donc c'est comme ça qu'on a recouvert
l'affaire platinique. On a découvert
toutes ces petites arrangements entre
amis qui se font dans toutes les
fédérations.
Donc voilà, il faut aussi reconnaître
une certaine un certain avantage tiré de
la de cet pouvoir extraordinaire que
s'est donné à la justice américaine.
Donc pour les embargos, on est
aujourd'hui à penser que il vaut mieux
faire des embargos ciblés.
Emargo ciblé, ça veut dire
on va essayer de d'empêcher refuser les
visas des personnalités qui tournent
autour du pouvoir. On va essayer de
faire condamner ou de saisir les avoirs
de ces personnalités, des choses comme
ça, en essayant de viser plutôt les
élites que la population. Bon, ça marche
ou ça marche pas. Enfin, en tout cas, on
essaie d'être un peu moins inhumain si
vous voulez que ce qui s'est passé avec
le l'Irak. Cela dit, comme Trump est un
homme qui visiblement
est un cowboy, donc il a décidé à
nouveau lui la totalité des embargos sur
l'Iran. Et on voit bien que là on est on
est en train de rentrer dans quelque
chose. Il y a une machine infernale.
Pourquoi ? Parce que finalement,
conclusion essentielle, aucun embargo
n'a jamais réussi à renverser un régime.
Aucun. Cuba, ça fait 60 ans qu'ils sont
sous embargot.
le Fidè a succédé Raoul a succédé à Fidè
et Brand
c'est les populations qui sont
sanctionnées
c'est le les trafics qui sont qui
prévalent
par exemple en Iran sous embargo à
l'époque précédente c'était les passes
d'aran qui tenaient les le trafic avec
la Turquie avec tous ces pays qui ne
respectaient pas l'embargo. Parce que
quand un embargo est voté à Washington
mais que c'est la frontière turque qui
ont subir les effets, vous imaginez bien
que les gens les commerçants turcs qui
sont à la frontière, ils en ont rien à
faire de ce qui s'est passé de ce qui a
été décidé à Washington. Donc tous les
pays frontaliers d'un pays sous embargot
ont eux de bonnes raisons de le
contourner. Et donc en l'occurrence,
c'est plutôt du côté du pays
sous-embargo que se font les trafics
parce qu'à ce moment-là, on sait qui va
trafiquer et comment. Donc c'est une
c'est une arme qu'on n pas qu'on utilise
de manière très différenciée. On n
jamais saisi les bien de la famille
Bush. Il y a des pays qui sont
totalement tenus à l'écart de toute
sanction comme l'Arabie Saoudite. Et par
contre quand on en trouve un qui peut
fonctionner qui remplit toutes les
cases, à ce moment-là, on est prêt à
mettre sur pied un embargo effroyable de
de dureté humaine, quoi.
Quand quand l'Iran fait des exercices
pour bloquer et prendre le contrôle du
D3.
Et alors quoi ?
C'est normal ?
Bah c'est pas normal plus que de le
qu'il y ait une 6e flotte dans la dans
le D3. Pourquoi ? Non mais je veux dire
faut aussi dire si les Iraniens regardez
maintenant que les Chinois ont une
flotte de haute mer. Tout le monde dit
ou là là la marine chinoise et cetera.
Le pétrole du golf s'en va pour
l'essentiel vers l'Asie. Bon alors le
jour où les Chinois vont faire rentrer
des bateaux de guerre dans le golf en
disant chez nous mais le pétrole il
vient chez nous. On va dire "Oh là là,
mais qu'est-ce c'est que cette puissance
déstabilisatrice qui vient dans cette
région du monde qui est si pacifique
Je veux dire tous les dirigeants
occidentaux pensent que la terre est
plate et qu'ils en sont le centre hein.
Donc que les Iraniens disent "Si vous
nous mettez sous embargo et si un
scénario de guerre, bien évidemment on
bloquera le détroit d'Ormouse."
C'est une réaction classique de pays qui
est sous embargo. C'est une zone
internationale et normalement ils ont
pas le droit de le faire mais en
situation de guerre ce qu'on a le droit
de faire ou de pas faire on a bien
Est-ce que les les États-Unis se prépare
à mettre sous embarque la Chine avec
leurs flotte qui stationnent dans le
dans le collier de perle ? Est-ce que la
réponse chinoise de de construire des
îles dans la mer de Chine pour
revendiquer
un espace territorial est une réaction ?
Non, ça c'était une ambition assez
ancienne des Chinois euh notamment de
d'annexer un certain nombre d'il qui
sont dans le dans la mer Jaune et dans
la mer de Chine ou qui était disputé
avec les Vietnamiens et cetera. Donc
donc comme effectivement euh la Chine a
franchi une étape, c'est devenu une
puissance avec une flotte de haute mer
et cetera, ils ont fait le coup
classique de planter le drapeau sur un
rocher où il y a rien et donc avec
l'idée que il puisse y avoir un jour une
zone économique exclusive dans lequelle
il pourrait y avoir des choses
intéressantes. La Chine est quand même
la seule grande puissance qui n'a aucune
ressource propre. dire il y a pas de
pétrole en Chine ou rien de
significatif.
Donc c'est une politique assez classique
où on plante le drapeau dans des îloss
où il y a il y a que les mouettes. Mais
on se dit peut-être qu'à terme vous
savez que par exemple
en face des présides au Maroc il y a un
îlo que il y a personne, il y a
simplement des oiseaux mais le jour où
les marocains ont voulu planter un
drapeau, c'est à 3 km de les Espagnols
ont immédiatement réagi en envoyant une
frégade pour faire que l'î reste
espagnol. Donc c'est pour vous dire que
la matière faut [grognement] pas
plaisanter avec les îs qui servent à
rien. Donc le là en l'occurrence les
Chinois ont cette habitude effectivement
maintenant de prendre conscience qu'ils
sont une puissance maritime. Et encore
une fois le jour où ils voudront
protéger leur propre voie
d'approvisionnement, ils nous feront
exactement le coût qu'on a fait
nous-même.
C'est-à-dire le fait que le signe de la
puissance, c'est de pouvoir dire aux
autres je ne vous pourrez pas faire ce
que je veux pas que vous fassiez.
C'est ça la puissance. Le fait qu'il y
ait beaucoup de bateaux américains dans
le collier de perle qui est la
principale route énergétique de la
Chine,
bah de toute façon la supériorité
militaire américaine est avérée, hein.
Il y a pas de il y a pas de doute en
nombre de porte-avion, qualité
opérationnelle et cetera et cetera. Mais
euh le on est dans des logiques de
puissance, c'est-à-dire on est dans la
rivalité franco-anglaise du 19e siècle
dans la course à la colonie. Là, on est
dans le l'instrumentalisation de la du
discours sur l'ennemi. Moi, je ferai
simplement remarquer que la Chine depuis
49 a mené, si je ne m'abuse de conflits,
un contre la l'Inde et un contre le
Vietnam. Or, pourtant, on pense que
c'est une puissance impérialisme
militariste qui va passer son temps à
faire la guerre. Alors que l'AN qui est
le pays de la paix et du non violence,
ça a fait plus d'une dizaine de conflits
contre le Pakistan, contre Austri Lanca
et cetera. Donc voyez qu'entre
l'apparence et la réalité, il faut
parfois prendre quelques mesures. C'est
pas ça veut pas dire que les les Chinois
soient des des angelous mais simplement
la montée en puissance de la Chine fait
que c'est beaucoup moins facile de
décider un embargo sur la Chine du côté
américain puisque les Chinois sont les
plus gros détenteurs de bond du trésor
américain. Ça veut dire que le jour où
ils mettent ses bons du trésor sur le
marché en les vendant à perte, le
l'économie américaine s'écroule. Donc on
respecte à ce moment-là, on est dans un
rapport de force. on n'est plus dans le
rapport de supériorité absolue et le
militaire n'est qu'un des aspects de
cette supériorité. En tout cas, sur le
plan économique, ils sont les Américains
sont beaucoup moins puissant et les
Chinois beaucoup plus puissants qu'il
était il y a une vingtaine d'années.
[grognement]
Quand on voit Poutine avec Sjing Ping se
faire des petits roulés au caviar, h
euh
c'est une erreur de l'Europe de d'avoir
craché sur les Russes pendant un certain
temps. C'est quoi ? Ben, c'est-à-dire
que finalement, on se rend compte
notamment avec cette affaire de la de
l'embargo sur l'Iran, que euh les
Américains, les Européens bien
évidemment ont énormément d'intérêt dans
les échanges avec les États-Unis. C'est
quand même notre principal partenaire et
cetera et cetera. Mais enfin, après la
guerre en Irak, après euh les décisions
de Trump, il y a quand même quelque
chose à mettre sur pied. C'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui, il faut avoir des
relations commerciales, économiques,
financières beaucoup plus diversifiées
que ça ne l' aujourd'hui. Ça veut dire
que aujourd'hui l'Europe est dans une
position de soumission.
Est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
développer ces échanges avec la Russie ?
développer ces échanges avec la Chine ?
La réponse est certainement oui. Si on
développe nos échanges avec l'Arabie
Saoudite, l'Arabie Saoudite, ils jouent
en première, ils jouent en première
division. Les Russes et les Chinois, ils
jouent en 2è division. Donc, on est sur
quelque chose où si c'est le critère de
du respect des droits de l'homme,
je trouve que on pourrait effectivement
réfléchir un peu plus sur le vote de
sanction. Encore une fois, je je prends
cet exemple. Mettre sous embargo, la
Russie et l'Iran qui sont deux gros
producteurs de pétrole, ça veut dire
qu'on va donner les clés de la
de l'énergie à l'Arabie Saoudite. Bon,
il y a d'autres producteurs évidemment.
Enfin, le Venezuela est mis aussi sous
embargo. Donc, je veux dire, on veut
faire monter les cours du pétrole et
rendre service à l'Arabie Saoudite, on
s'y prendrait pas autrement. D'ailleurs,
l'Allemagne est en désaccord, hein, sur
les sanctions, notamment à l'égard du
pétrole,
l'Arabie Saoudite, qu'est-ce qu'on peut
en dire ?
On peut dire que d'abord ils ont une
très bonne politique de communication.
Oui, parce qu'ils ont un prince héritier
qui est un beau mec, qui sourit, qui a
qu'une seule femme et deux enfants,
enfin officiellement.
Et donc, il a fait cette tournée
formidable qui a été couverte par tous
les médias où tout à coup, il a annoncé
que les femmes allaient pouvoir
conduire, ce qui a été salué comme une
grande avancée de la démocratie.
Bon, je pense que le jour où Kim Jongoun
annoncera qu'il ouvre à McDonald's à
Pyongang, on dira "La démocratie
progresse" quoi. C'est à peu près de cet
ordre-là. Donc en fait rapidement le
voile s'est déchiré. C'est-à-dire qu'on
a vu il y a 15 jours que le procureur du
roi qui est quand même qui dépend
directement du roi a demandé la
condamnation à mort de cinq manifestants
dont une femme. Cinq manifestants qui
ont fait des manifestations sans
violence mais ils sont chiit. Donc c'est
un tort ça c'est incurable. La femme est
simplement une femme qui a demandé à
avoir plus de droits en tant que femme
que les droits des femmes soient plus
respectés. Demande la condamnation à
mort. Bon
par décapitation.
Ah je ne sais pas. Ça c'est une bonne
question. Normalement, les décapitations
se passent sur l'espace public.
Effectivement, il retransmise à la
télévision en direct. Bon, donc euh je
ne sais pas pour la femme, je sais pas
parce qu'il va falloir la dévoiler pour
la décapiter ou alors peut-être qu'ils
vont la décapiter sans la dévoiler,
c'est possible.
Est-ce qu'ils vont peut-être la lapider
avant ?
Non, ça c'est l'adultère. Faut pas
confondre toutes les peines. Non, non,
pas confondre. Non, il y a
malheureusement des scènes qui circulent
sur internet notamment, je me souviens
d'une scène où on il décapite une femme
qui a été accusée d'avoir volé ses ses
patrons. C'était une fille de de
Birmanie.
C'est absolument effroyable. C'est sur
un parking public, les mecs continuent à
circuler et cetera et et elle a fini ce
débat. Enfin bref, c'est c'est une scène
effroyable. Effroyable. C'était pas une
Philippine
ou peut-être une Philippine. Oui, c'est
ça. Enfin, c'était une fille qui avait
été accusée d'un truc tout à fait bénin
et donc il va être décapité sur une
plage publique. Sur une place publique.
Le la performance étant probablement euh
il y a eu deux grands moments comme ça
de décapitation en public en Arabie
Saoudite après l'occupation de la Grande
Mosquée
en 79 où là effectivement je crois
qu'ils avaient réussi à capturer vivant
64 types qui ont été décapités dans
quatre villes d'Arabie Saoudite en
direct à la télévision. Donc là c'est un
grand spectacle. Je veux dire, c'est
c'est l'équivalent de l'Eurovision quoi
si on doit de comparer. Et là récemment,
ils ont refait la même chose l'année
dernière ou il y a un an et demi où ils
ont décapité des djihadistes et dans
l'eau, ils ont mis un imam un imam chiit
parce que l'imam chiit qui en
l'occurrence était simplement demandant
les que les droits des chiites d'Arabie
Saoudite qui sont quand même entre 10 et
15 % de la population soient à peu près
écounit.
Visiblement la chose n'a pas plu donc il
a été décapité. Alors actuellement, il y
a deux personnes qui sont en prison qui
sont particulièrement comment dirait
dont les conditions de détention et de
condamnation sont particulièrement
effroyable. Il y a donc le neveu de ce
cet imam qui s'appelle NIMRE, le neveu
ayant été condamné parce qu'il est le
neveu. Bon et donc lui la condamnation
est un peu plus comment dire créative de
la part des des Saoudiens puisque il
doit être décapité et puis ensuite son
corps doit être exposé, crucifié, exposé
jusqu'à ce que les chas pourissent. Donc
les Saoudiens ont un certain sens du
spectacle, c'est le moins qu'on puisse
le reconnaître. L'autre cas absolument
odieux, c'est celui de RF Badai. RF
Badawioui est un type qui sur son blog
avait simplement expliqué
que un petit peu plus de liberté, un peu
plus de distance critique, enfin
quelques quelques comment dire distance
critique vis-à-vis de l'Islam a été
condamné pour insulte à l'islam,
10 ans de prison et 1000 coups de fouet
qu'il reçoit par tranche de de 50 ou
100, je sais plus. Donc il est on le
sort régulièrement de prison pour lui
donner des coups de fouet et cetera.
Euh je n'ai pas vu de pétition du 5e et
du 6e arrondissement pour la défense de
R Badaoui. Donc je ne sais pas si c'est
parce que on n'en parle pas assez. Sa
femme est a obtenu le statut de réfugié
politique au Canada et c'est une des
raisons de la comment dire de cette
tension qui s'est faite entre le Canada
et le et l'Arabie Saoudite où les
Canadiens se sont permis de critiquer
ces condamnations et ben la sanction est
tombée immédiatement. L'Arabie Saoudite
a suspendu toutes les relations
diplomatiques avec le Canada. Toutes,
sauf peut-être, et c'est une question à
laquelle je ne peux pas répondre, le
contrat de 10 milliards de dollars qu'a
signé le Canada pour la livraison de
blindé à l'Arabie Saoudite dont je ne
sais s'il a été suspendu ou si en dépit
de cette de ces tourments en
diplomatique, on il continue à entrer en
en activité. Donc ça c'est à vos c'est
vos spécialistes du Canada, vos
auditeurs qui peut-être pourront
apporter une réponse.
La France continue de les caresser un
peu dans le sens du poil, même beaucoup.
Non, c'est il faut pas le dire les
caresser dans le sens du poil. La France
est dans une observation
critique.
C'est-à-dire qu'elle a perdu son réflexe
de déglultition.
Non, c'est-à-dire qu'elle observe, comme
on dit dans les communiqués officiels,
avec beaucoup de préoccupation
l'évolution de la situation au Yémen.
Rien sur les condamnations à mort. J'ai
pas vu de communiquer mais par exemple,
j'ai un exemple de la de communiqué
particulièrement croquignolé fait par le
Kedors euh quand il y a eu ce
bombardement sur cette école au Yémen où
il y a eu 60 gosses qui ont été tués.
Donc il y a eu un communiqué du Genoré
qui dit en gros je vous l' fait brève la
France exprime sa profonde préoccupation
devant les événements récents qui sont
déroulés au Yémen et demande une enquête
indépendante sur l'origine de cette
catastrophe comme si les outils avaient
une aviation. C'est quand même pas mal.
L'enquête a été confiée à
pas d'enquête. Vous avez demandé une
enquête indépendante au Yémen ou quoi ?
Vous allez confié à l'Arabie Saoudite.
Qui est le type qui va aller faire une
enquête pour dire que c'est des avions
qui ont lancé une bombe sur une école ?
C'est les Américains qui fournissent les
coordonnées mais malheureusement les
saoudiens sont pas de bons pilotes. Donc
je ne sais pas si c'est un acte
involontaire ou volontaire mais enfin
toujours est-il que c'est pas la peine
de faire une enquête quoi.
[grognement]
On va continuer longtemps ou qu'est-ce
qui va nous arrêter à les regarder avec
des des lunettes roses ? Je pense qu'on
va continuer assez longtemps. Oui,
pourquoi ?
Oui, oui, je pense. Il y a pas de je
sens pas de réaction qui qui prennent de
distance. Alors non, si c'est j'exagère
un peu. Quand mon bouquin est sorti sur
docteur Saoumur de Jjihad, j'ai eu droit
à une note incendiaire du K d'oré qui a
été tellement ridicule que le Canadaché
en a fait une brève. Donc ça ça fait
toujours plaisir parce que alors ils
avaient confié la rédaction de cette
note à un type qui est un converti qui
était notre représentant à
l'organisation de la coopération
islamique Ariad, c'est-à-dire le type
qui était placé évidemment au centre de
l'observation de du fonctionnement de la
société saoudienne. Tous les témoignages
qu'on a de gens ayant vécu en Arabie
Saoudite sont tous d'accord avec mon
témo avec la façon dont j'ai analysé la
situation. Sauf ce type du qu d'ors qui
effectivement lui s'est permis une note
de démolition complète de mon de mon
livre. Bon donc à l'époque
comment il s'appelle ?
Non je vais pas donner. Donc donc le
type était comment dire c'était dans
l'air du temps. On va pas traiter
l'Arabie Saoudite comme si c'était un
espèce de rock state. Non pas sérieux.
Et puis depuis la je remarque que tout a
changé, c'est-à-dire le dernier rapport
alara qui vient de sortir là sur l'islam
de enfin sur comment lutter contre la
radicalisation utilise continuellement
le le terme wabisation de l'islam tout
le temps. Je me dis attends ce lit de ce
type que se passe-t-il ? Il se rend pas
compte de ce qu'il écrit aujourd'hui
dans le point il y a un truc un article
un type qui dit a-t-on le droit de
critiquer l'Arabie Saoudite ? Donc on
est en train de changer parce que
effectivement je veux dire on pouvez pas
raconter aux français que l'Arabie
Saoudite et cette espèce de paradis sur
terre. Vous savez qu'il y a l'Arabie
Saoudite présente une vidéo qu'il faut
trouver sur internet qui est absolument
extraordinaire parce qu'il veulent créer
une zone franche à la à la limite de la
Jordanie d'Israël dans lesquelles les
entreprises étrangères pourraient venir
s'implanter, travailler et cetera et
cetera. [grognement]
Et alors ce qui est très rigolo, c'est
qu'on a l'impression que c'est le club
MED parce qu'il y a quand même des
femmes qui circulent. On sent que les
épouser là contentes et cetera. Donc je
me dis formidable, les Anglo-Saxons sont
bien meilleurs que nous pour vendre de
la publicité. Euh
le Qatar euh ça va être une île bientôt.
Qatar. Alors oui. Alors l'autre aspect
très intéressant sur l'Arabie Saoudite,
c'est donc cette espèce de
d'ubris
qui s'est déclenché chez les Saoudiens
avec la diplomatie que le Qatar a
développé depuis une quinzaine d'années.
Le Qatar, en peu de mots,
c'est une presquille qui tout à coup a
été inondée de pognon parce queon a
découvert un des plus grands champs
gaziers qu'elle partage avec l'Iran au
milieu du Golfers.
Et donc le l'Irak, le Qatar s'est tout à
coup enrichi de manière totalement
disproportionnée. Et donc ils ont mené
une diplomatie qui est à la fois
intelligente et stupide, c'est-à-dire
intelligente au sens où ils sont dit il
faut exister, donc il faut faire naître
des moyens d'identification du Qatar. Et
donc ils ont créé un musée des arts
islamiques. Il y avait pas de musée des
arts islamiques dans le le golf persque.
Euh ils ont créé un certain nombre de
choses. Ils ont acheté des biens à
l'étrangers comme le Parissing-Germain
et cetera. Bon et donc en au-delà de ce
qui était ce cette espèce de politique
intelligente, euh il y a eu cette
politique stupide que l' appelait la
diplomatie du chéquier. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils sont dit "Ben tous les mecs qu'on
va inviter, les parlementaires et cetera
et cetera, les journalistes et autres,
pas les journalistes, je suis pas sûr
mais enfin en tout cas il y a il y a
quelques bouquins qui ont été faits par
des journalistes qui ont épinglé des tas
de gens qui passaient beaucoup de gens
de temps au cachtard où probablement
sous l'oreiller il devait trouver une
enveloppe avec des des billets usagers
avec des numéros qui suivent pas quoi.
Et donc ça a été cette diplomatie du
chéqui a été tellement ridicule que tout
à coup le cadavre s'est rendu compte que
le problème dans une démocratie c'est
que les choses se savent. Bon et donc
ils ont soudainement arrêté. Alors
l'autre aspect qui est aujourd'hui celui
qui est le plus cocasse, c'est que eux
ils ont continué à financer les frères
musulmans dans toutes les quand il y a
eu les révolutions euh arabes. Ils ont
financé les frères musulmans et les
frères musulmans ont été le seul parti
un peu organisé d'opposition et donc
avec l'argent Qatarie, ils ont gagné bon
la plupart des élections en Tunisie, en
Égypte et cetera. Bon et du coup c'est
l'Arabie Saoudite qui accuse le Qatar de
financer le terrorisme.
Fantastique non ? Donc on a
deux pays qui s'accusent mutal parce que
le Qatar lui accuse l'Arabie Saoudite de
financer les salafistes. Donc on est sur
de
un scénario absolument surréaliste où
vous avez deux pays qui s'accusent
mutuellement de financer le terrorisme.
La conséquence de ça, c'est que cette
volonté d'indépendance du Qatar se
traduit en particulier par le fait que
le pays a été mis sous embargot en juin
de l'année dernière.
embargo total hein, c'est-à-dire plus
aucun échange, plus interdiction de
survol du de la péninsule par les avions
de Qatar Oise, arrêt des
approvisionnements.
Et donc une tension qui est tout à fait
étonnante dans cette dans ce contexte-là
parce que le scénario de la guerre est
exclu parce que on ça fait des ordres
dans un pays où c'est suffisamment
explosif et puis en plus il y a l'Iran
avec lequel le Qatar a de bons a de bons
rapports. Donc le scénario de la guerre
est exclu.
Le le scénario de l'embargo, il pose
surtout des problèmes aux entreprises
étrangères puisque finalement des
entreprises qui travaillent dans le
golf, elles ont des activités à Abu
Dhabi, elles ont des activités dans en
Arabie Saoudite et aussi au Qatar. Donc
le
moi j'ai été l'année dernière mandaté
pour une étude justement sur ce
sujet-là, c'est-à-dire pour essayer de
comprendre quel était le risque que
subissait risqu de subir les entreprises
françaises et européennes. Et en fait,
j'ai découvert avec surprise que
l'embargo s'est retourné contre ses
auteurs. C'est-à-dire que par exemple
l'Arabie Saoudite
exporter des produits alimentaires frais
vers le Qatar puisque c'est c'est une
frontière tout à fait enfin je veux dire
c'est ces deux pays qui sont non
seulement frontali mais en plus le Qatar
est minuscule à côté de l'Arabie
Saoudite donc ils achetaient des
produits frais
donc immédiatement les Hollandais les
Turcs les Français tout le monde s'est
précipite en disant vous voulez du
produit frais on a tout ce qu'il vous
faut et en plus ils ont découvert qu'ils
étaient meilleurs de meilleure qualité
moins chers bon deuxième chose tous les
produits occidentaux qui arrivaient au
Qatar ou asiatique était des
réexportations depuis Dubaï et donc
Dubaï tout à coup se trouvait interdit
de réexporter Valatar. Donc ils ont
perdu à peu près 600 millions de dollars
de d'activité annuelle simplement dans
la réexportation vers le Qatar. le port
de DOA qui est construit à la à la
taille des pays du golf qui était
surdimensionné, sous-exploité, tout à
coup se retrouve sa fonction normale.
Donc le cet échec de la cet échec de
l'embargo pose évidemment le problème de
qu'est-ce qu'on va prendre en otage les
entreprises étrangères puisque
effectivement c'est le seul moyen de
pression qu'ils avaient. Il y a pas
d'échange en intragolfien
pour une raison assez simple, c'est que
vous allez pas mettre un émérien sous
l'autorité d'un Qatar ou un saoudien
sous l'autorité d'un Qatar. Donc on est
vraiment sur sur des scénarios
ridicules. Donc il y a très peu
d'échange entre les pays du golf et donc
le risque était que on prenne des
entreprises étrangères en otage.
Et enfin moi le rapport que j'ai fait,
il a été transmis à l'Élysée. Quand
Macron est allé dans le
dans la région, il aura fait comprendre
qu'il s'amuse pas à prendre des
entreprises françaises en otage. Il dit
savez je savais je sais ce que vous avez
en tête. Bon
visiblement ça a été respecté. Je n'ai
pas eu vent de menace excepté il y avait
eu une menace sur HSBC, la banque suisse
la banque anglaise
qui dont on disait c'est vous choisissez
c'est au nous mais il y a pas j'ai pas
eu d'autres exemples de d'arbitrage
comme ça.
Et donc on est aujourd'hui dans cette
situation où l'Arabie Saoudite Mohamed
Ben Salmad le célèbre réformateur et
doit trépigner parce que rien ne marche
il y a aucun moyen de présence sur le
Qatar. Donc cette idée extraordinaire
inventé pour vous donner une idée quand
même le quand il y a eu l'application
des sanctions ça a été mais d'une
humiliation et d'une bêtise
extraordinaire. Les pèlerins Qataris qui
se trouvaient à la Mec n'ont pas pu
rentrer que les avions de Qatar qui
était interdit. Donc il a fallu que le
Qatar loue une compagnie étrangère qui
pouvait se poser à la Mec pour ensuite
pouvoir rapatrier ses propres pélerins.
Même les chameaux ont été sanctionnés
puisque les chameaux du Qatar comme l'î
est très petite ils allaient en pâturage
du côté de l'Arabie Saoudit. Donc
craque, on a fermé la frontière. les
chameaux pouvaient plus passer. Et de
temps en temps, les Saoudiens ouvraient
un peu la frontière. Donc les chameaux
se précipitaient et craqu non, il il y a
eu des chameaux qui se sont écrasé
mutuellement parce qu'ils ouvraient pas
la porte complètement quand même. Donc
des petits petits chameaux qui ont été
écrasés dans le troupeau et cetera.
Enfin vraiment ça a été cloche mer le en
Asie en dans le golf Persy. Et donc
aujourd'hui on est dans cette situation
où l'idée nouvelle est probablement
conseillée par
un conseiller imaginatif, c'est de faire
de du Qatar une île. Donc l'idée
récente, c'est de creuser un énorme
canal qui ferait que le Qatar ne
correspondrait plus ne pourrait plus
communiquer avec l'Arabie Saoudite par
voie terrestre. Je pense que j'ai
entendu dire qu'il y avait déjà quatre
entreprises qui avaient candidaté hein
pour la construction du canal.
Mohamed Ben Salman quand il est arrivé
au pouvoir,
il a mis beaucoup de personnes du
royaume en prison dans des hôtels.
Non, soyez pas injuste. Il a emprisonné
tous ses petits camarades dans l'hôtel
Ritz quand même. C'est pas dans les
hôtels, il les a pas mis dans hôtel 3
étoiles. Il l'a fait venir en leur
disant, j'ai une conférence importante
et cetera. Quand ils sont rentrés, ils
auront tous piqué leur téléphone
portable et ensuite il aura réparti les
chambres et ils ont empêché de sortir.
Le premier qui est sorti est sorti au
bout de 2 jours après avoir signé un
chèque d'un milliard de dollars. Ce qui
a se pensé que c'est la chambre la plus
chère que je connaisse dans l'histoire
de l'humanité parce que ça fait la
chambre à 500 millions de dollars quand
même la nuit. C'est pas mal. Et puis il
aura tous fait cracher des sommes
parfois très importantes justement pour
montrer que sa volonté de lutte contre
la corruption.
Donc effectivement, il y a ils sont
sortis par petit morceau et donc il a
ramassé, je sais plus entre 60 et 100
milliards, je sais plus, enfin quelque
chose d'assez si assez important. Ce qui
est d'autant plus important
qu'effectivement quand même le prix du
pétrole est en bas, il y avait besoin
d'argent. Il y en a un qui est mort
semble-t-il sous la torture mais enfin
bon on parle pas de ça, ça fait des
ordres. Enfin, il y a un des types qui a
été très mal mené dans le
dans le rit
dans le rit. Mais enfin, être malmené
dans le rit, ça vous positionne un homme
quand même hein. C'est mieux que d'être
torturé dans les sous-sols de la rue
l'oriston. Et donc c'est il y en a un
qui est mort. Bon le donc le personnage
a eu tout à coup cette aura. Regardez,
c'est ce type qui veut réformer l'Arabie
Saoudite. En plus il autorise les femmes
à conduire et même il autorise les
femmes à assister au match de foot quand
même. Alors le problème c'est qu'entre
temps il s'est payé un Y de 500 millions
de dollars.
Il a racheté un org russe donc c'est
pour on est entre gens qui s'entendont.
Il s'est fait construire un château. Il
a racheté un château qui est
à l'ouv
qui est un petit Versaill.
tout tout refait à l'identique avec des
matériaux contemporains. Bon, où il y a
un parc de 50 hectares, je crois autour.
Et puis le dernier folie qu'il a faite,
je me souviens plus ce que c'est. Enfin,
on est dans cet ordre de prix, c'està
dire 300 500 millions de dollars
l'acquisition. Et donc entre ce
personnage qui lutte contre la
corruption et puis ces petites phrases
qui se pasent Ah si il y a un épisode
qu'il faut que je vous raconte parce
qu'il est trop cocasse.
Donc le il rachète le yotour russe et
donc le le bateau se rapatrie vers le
les ports saouiens et pam il se plante
dans le détroit de Charmelcher
et on a appris par la suite qu'il y
avait un hélicoptère qui était venu pour
éiporter les femmes qui étaient à bord
qui devait pas être madame Ben Salman
mais il fallait les faire sortir pour
pas que la presse s'intéresse à ce qui
se passait sur le Yotte. des femmes
d'équipage. Non, [soupir]
très certainement. Très certainement.
C'est un peu comme les ch
Non, c'est pour dire quoi ? C'est pour
dire
chambre d'hôtel Garni, c'est ça ?
C'était une chambre d'hôtel Garni mais
qui flottait.
Oui, c'est ce qu'on me disait dans les
péarchés de l'armement. il y avait une
couverture quoi. Et on offrait la
couverture. Les donc le le truc est
extraordinaire parce que l'Arabie
Saoudite c'est le pays dans lequel
l'hypocrisie est est élevé au rang d'un
art majeur quoi. Dans toutes les
démocraties, l'hypocrisie joue les mecs
ont tous leur arrangement, le pouvoir
attire du monde et cetera et mais là il
y a en plus une façade de pureté de
machin. Attention chez nous on plaisante
pas et il y a cette hiérarchie
religieuse qui est là évidemment pour
on va on va rebondir sur le côté
religieux et le la radicalisation
religieuse un peu plus tard. les
véléités nucléaires de l'Arabie
Saoudite.
Moi, j'avoue que j'y crois pas trop, en
tout cas pas comme vos politiques
directes, que par contre il passe un
accord avec le Pakistan qui lui a le
savoir-faire, les militaires et cetera
pour que ce soit une espèce de garantie
nucléaire, que ce soit une transfert de
savoir-faire, une installation, des
installations sur le territoire, ça
c'est possible. En fait, l'armée
saoudienne, seuls les officiers sont
saoudiens. Tous les hommes de troupes
sont et notamment dans les disciplines
les plus difficiles à maîtriser sont pas
des saoudiens. Vous allez pas mettre un
saoudien dans un sous-marin.
Voilà. Donc, mais parce que les types
sont n'ont pas cette tradition déjà pour
former une génération de marins pour de
la marine de guerre avec la discipline
que ça impose, l'organisation et cetera,
il faut une bonne génération. Mais des
sous-marinés, il faut deux générations.
Donc euh si ça fait des années qu'on
négocia avec l'Arabie Saoudite pour la
vente de sous-marin.
Le problème, on a deux problèmes, c'est
que l'Arabie Saoudite n'a aucun port en
eau profonde parce que c'est soit au
Mand d'un côté, soit le Yémen de
l'autre. Mais les ports saoudiens sont
soit sur le golf persque, soit sur la
mer rouge. Donc ça veut dire que quand
vous faites sortir un bateau de votre
mer, il y a quand même un risque. Bon
mais en fait ça fait rien. On discute,
on discute, on discute et peut-être
qu'un jour on va les convaincre
d'acheter des sous-marins après tout. Il
y en a plein d'autres qui en avaient,
l'Albanie aussi en avait. Donc il y a
pas de raison que l'Arabie Saoudite n'en
a pas. Et puis ils ont eu quand même
l'expérience désagréable que les
Saoudiens, les les Iraniens avaient
acheté des sous-marins kilo euh russes à
une certaine époque et donc tout à coup,
on a pensé que c'était une espèce de
déstabilisation majeure. Donc le l'armée
saoudienne et les forces de sécurité
saoudienne sont composées par
nationalité. Les policiers sont
soudanis, les marins sont pakistanis et
cetera.
Donc l'idée de faire du nucléaire avec
le niveau technologique que ça suppose
les garanties de sécurité qu'il faut
prendre le la formation des mecs, des
techniciens, des ingénieurs et cetera.
Enfin, moi je trouve que c'est
inaccessible. Autant ça me paraît
accessible à l'Iran, autant ça me paraît
inaccessible à l'Arabie Saoudite.
Est-ce que ces vélités sont du fait que
l'Arabie Saoudite commence à manquer de
pétrole ?
Non, ils manqueront pas de pétrole. Moi
je le scénario de la fin du pétrole,
c'est une prévision glissante. C'estàd
que il y a une trentaine d'années, on
m'expliquait que le pic était atteint
machin à telle date, puis après le pic,
il arrête pas de reculer. Le tous les
pays du golf ont tous la même
préoccupation en tête et tous les
dirigeants
ont à peu près la même idée, c'est il
faut quand même diversifier cette
économie parce que construire une
économie rentière, ça vous fait des
rentiers.
C'est les mecs sont habitués à ce que
l'électricité soit gratuite, que les
études soient payées, de pas payer
d'impôt et cetera et à chaque fois que
le baissent du prix du pétrole, ils le
sentent comme une injustice profonde
puisque tout à coup on leur demande de
payer l'électricité
travailler plus de 2 heures par jour.
Alors non, n'allons pas si loin quand
même. N'allons pas si loin. Donc
effectivement, il y a toujours
l'hypothèse que les types vont trouver.
Par exemple, l'économie rentière, c'est
effectivement fournir du travail. Ça
veut dire fournir un salaire, ça veut
pas dire fournir un travail. Par
exemple, le Kit est un pays dans lequel
le taux de fonctionner était supérieur à
l'URSS. parce que tout le monde était
employé de l'État. Et donc en Arabie
Saoudite, c'est pareil, vous avez une
catégorie d'hommes d'affaires, de gens
qui effectivement font des affaires
internationale, qui ont des des avoirs à
droite, à gauche et cetera et cetera. Et
puis vous avez une masse de gens de
classe moyenne qui sont habitués à bien
vivre et qui travaillent euh si on veut
quoi. Bon donc le faire tout à coup des
filières de formation technologique avec
des examens à passer pour ensuite faire
des recruter les meilleurs techniciens
pour faire ensuite une filière nucléaire
et cetera ou même faire des filières de
haute technologie, c'est très compliqué.
Alors les anglais ont quand même à
savoir faire que nous n'avons pas.
C'est-à-dire le cabinet MINC a vendu le
même plan vision 2025 ou 2030 à tous les
pays du golf.
ont tous alors c'est les
biotechnologies, les technologies de
l'information, les nanotechnologies et
cetera. Extraordinaire les mecs, ils ont
vendu le même à tout le monde et
effectivement tout le monde est en train
de ramer pour se dire comment je fais
j'addate mon plan. Donc l'Arabie
Saoudite à cause de ses contraintes de
vie, à cause des difficultés de vie en
Arabie Saoudite et notamment cette
pression des religieux, c'est
probablement pas le pays qui a le plus
d'avantage. C'est certainement le plus
riche mais c'est pas celui qui attirera
le plus facilement des ingénieurs
étrangers pour venir travailler en
Arabie Saoudite. Donc tous les ils sont
en concurrence avec les Émirats qui
présentent évidemment beaucoup plus
d'atout et évidemment avec le Qatar qui
lui a beaucoup d'argent par tête
d'habitant. C'est le niveau de ville le
plus élevé de la planète le Qatar.
Une petite question d'internet. On n pas
vu ce fameux documentaire donc peut-être
que vous l'avez vu.
Donc plein de questions sur le
documentaire interdit par la chaîne
Aljazira qui dé parenthèses qui dévoile
les méthodes du groupe de pression
américain favorable à Israël.
Mais ça a été interdit. Pourquoi ? Si
c'est Aljazira, c'est le Qatar qui l'a
diffusé.
J'en ai strictement aucune idée.
Parce que le Qatar a reconnu Israël
hein. Parce que l'originalité du Qatar
dans sa diplomatie, c'est que justement
quand il y a eu les négociations de
paix, ils ont reconnu Israël. Et donc je
vois pas pourquoi ce serait Alzira qui
censurerait le Bah je sais pas. Non, je
connais pas, je peux rien vous dire.
On me dit les pression du Qatar pour que
Aljazira ne diffuse pas
le documentaire.
Je sais pas, je peux rien dire. Je veux
pas, je connais pas. J'ai pas vu le
documentaire. Je vois.
Alors, on va passer au radicalisme
religieux. Hm
hm. Les radicalismes.
Les radicalismes. Euh, on en est où ? On
fait quoi ? On va où ?
Bah euh
bon, c'est un sujet sur lequel j'ai
commencé à travailler
il y a que j'avais toujours en tête
depuis un certain temps mais qui me
préoccupait parce que
euh en fait il y a des radicalismes
religieux aujourd'hui dans toutes les
grandes aires religieuses de la planète,
c'està-dire les néoangéliques
américains, les juifs radicaux des
territoires occupés, les islamistes
évidemment, mais aujourd'hui les
hindouistes et les bouddhistes qui s'y
mettent. Ça veut dire qu'on est au-delà
de la première niveau de conclusion
qu'on avait, c'était le monothéisme et
par nature porteur d'intolérance.
Article 1er, seulement Dieu et le bon.
Et donc on pensait que cette ce retour
du religieux se traduisait dans les
monothéismes par une espèce de forme de
le radicalisme. La différence entre le
fondamentalisme et le radicalisme, c'est
que le radicalisme légitime la violence.
Bon, les mormons, les amiches sont des
gens qui ne sont violents, qui le
pratiquent, qui ne se mêlent pas de
politique. Donc c'est des
fondamentalistes, c'est pas des
radicaux. Par contre, les radicaux sont
des gens qui vont légitimer avec des
argumentaires religieux et théologiques
l'utilisation de la violence contre
l'autre. Bon, pourquoi je dis ça ? Parce
que finalement, il y a pas que le
terrorisme dans le radicalisme. C'estàd
quand on a des groupes de pression
religieux qui poussent le gouvernement
américain à intervenir en Irak comme ça
s'est fait en 2004 et que on explique
que Saddam Hussein est le nouveau
Nabucodonosaur,
c'est-à-dire qu'on prend une référence
religieuse pour dire on qu'est-ce qu'on
entend par là ? C'est ce que c'était
Jimmy Falwell, je crois qu'il disait ça.
Ça veut dire que on est dans un
processus théologique. La destruction de
la bicicodonosaure annonce l'apocalypse
et le retour du Messie. On n'est plus
dans une logique scientifique laïque
d'étude de la réalité
où où le le la le fait que le grand
Israël apparaisse fera revenir
Jésus-Christ sur terre. Alors, ce qui
est très rigolo, c'est que donc il y a
les juifs intégristes pour qui euh cette
terre nous a été donnée par Dieu. Donc,
il est pas question de rétrocéder 1 cm²
au Palestinien. Ça c'est la position du
bloc de la foi. Et donc l'idée même de
la négociation est est théologiquement
interdit.
le les évangéliques américains sont plus
perfides parce que eux ils disent
effectivement la destruction de Saddam
Hussein de Nabodonosaur annonce et la
constitution du grand Israël est l'étape
annoncée par la Bible avant le retour de
du Messie. Et donc une fois que le
Messie va y revenir, les juifs vont être
convertis au christianisme. Mais ça
visiblement ça les choque pas. Donc ils
s'entendent très bien.
Et puis vous avez donc d'une part les
populations, les religions qui pensent
que l'apocalypse est sur le point
d'arriver. C'est la position des des
salafistes. Et donc il y a toujours
l'idée que le Messie va revenir un jour
ou l'autre et donc il faut purifier le
monde avant que le Messie n'apparaisse
et que et cetera et cetera.
Et se soumettre à Allah,
bah se soumettre à Dieu de toute façon.
C'est-à-dire que la caractéristique des
radicalismes, encore une fois, je parle
de y compris de religion polythéiste,
hein, puisque l'hindouisme et le
bouddhisme, c'est pareil,
sont les nouvelles formes du
totalitarisme. C'est-à-dire que ce qui
les caractérise, c'est plusieurs choses.
D'abord, c'est la lecture littérale des
textes. Ça veut dire qu'on a pas le
droit d'interprétation sur le sur les
textes puisqu'ils sont par nature
incréés, c'est-à-dire donnés par Dieu.
J'ai pas très bien percé le mystère de
la transmission de des textes religieux
puisque ni Moïse, ni Jésus, ni Mahometh,
ni Boudha n'ont jamais créé une ligne de
leur main. Donc il faut croire qu'il y a
encore des moyens de transmission qu'on
n pas totalement identifié.
Le Coran a été formalisé à peu près, je
crois que 70 ans après la mort de
Mahometh. Les évangiles pour ce qui
parle que Jésus ont été fait après. Et
puis il y a même eu des évangiles
hippocrites. Enfin bref, donc si vous
voulez si tu veux, il y a vraiment un
truc qui est une espèce d'interrogation
intellectuelle, c'est comment peut-on se
convaincre que ces textes sont incréés
si on se penche un temps soit peu sur le
leur mode de rédaction. Bon, je reste de
côté que pour les pour les bouddhistes,
le texte religieux, ça fait à peu près
24000 pages. Donc, c'est un peu plus
compliqué de respecter toutes les
règles, mais enfin c'est pour dire que
c'est pas grave. Le principe, c'est le
texte doit être respecté à la règle. La
deuxième chose, c'est le processus
intellectuel de construction de ces
radicalismes qui est totalement
similaire.
Il est similaire chronologiquement,
c'est-à-dire que les fondateurs de ceux
qui ont posé les bases de ces retours
religieux sont tous à peu près des gens
du 19e milieu du 19e siècle et même un
peu avant pour ce qui concerne
l'islamisme. Abdel Wahab, le fondateur
du boabisme est est un contemporain de
Voltaire.
Et évidemment pour nous pourquoi se
préoccuper de ce mec ? On est
aujourd'hui plutôt dans l'époque où
c'est Voltaire qui est en train de
perdre la partie he quand même. Pareil
en Inde, le type qui va formaliser
l'hindouisme militant qui s'appelle
Savarcar est un type qui va poser comme
condition évidemment comme réaction à la
présence des Britanniques, à la présence
des des pasteurs protestants que il sent
une espèce de comment dire de
d'intrusion religieuse et de
bouleversement de l'identité indienne.
Et donc il va formaliser le fait que
l'Inde est un pays hindouiste. Musulman
ça c'est des intrus hein, c'est des
occupants.
Et donc il va progressivement diffuser,
ça va donner naissance à un certain
nombre de partis dont un qui est
aujourd'hui au pouvoir qui est le BJP.
Bon euh on a le même processus en dans
le monde arabe où effectivement
l'embalisme de Abdel Wahab va donner
naissance au wahabisme et au salafisme.
Au début du siècle, on a le les premiers
penseurs des frères musulmans. Donc si
on a si tu veux, on a eu dans beaucoup
d'endroits cette espèce de retour du
religieux qui a pris une forme de
dénonciation et de forme de
militantisme.
Par exemple, dans les pays colonisés,
c'est la dénonciation évidemment de la
présence des colonisateurs qui ont une
religion différente et qui pensent que
la seule véritable bonne religion, c'est
le christianisme. Et puis dans les pays
où ils sont au pouvoir, par exemple,
comme aux États-Unis, ce qui est
intéressant, c'est qu'il y a cette
montée du radicalisme néoangélique et
comment dire par se fait par étape qu'on
appelle les grands réveils. C'est-à-dire
que tout à coup, face à l'évolution de
la société, face à laïcisation, la
libération des mœurs à chaque fois il y
a une espèce de de réaction religieuse.
Et ce qui est très intéressant, c'est
que le premier grand réveil est une
réaction contre l'arrivée de migrants
venus d'Italie et d'Espagne et qui sont
catholiques.
Parce qu'on est dans la tradition des
guerres de religion. C'est-à-dire que
ceux qui se sont barrés aux États-Unis
étaient des gens qui étaient persécutés
par l'église catholique pendant les
guerres de religion. Les pères
fondateurs, le le Mayfower, c'est ça.
C'est des migrants de gens persécutés
qui vont trouver en aux États-Unis le
moyen de d'appliquer le paradis sur
terre.
Et donc cette arrivée de migrants
catholiques qui vont changer la nature
de la religion dominante s'il s'agit
même pas de de c'est pas même pas des
des des musulmans ou des juifs ni quoi
que ce soit. Non, c'est cette inquiétude
face à l'arrivée des Irlandais, des
catholiques, des des Italiens, des
Espagnols, quoi. Et donc ça ça vous te
donne une espèce de réaction encore une
fois de radicalisme sur le thème. Ces
gens-là sont pas comme nous, quoi. Donc
on est sur des réactions qui sont
évidemment à des bases sociologiques et
politiques un peu spécifiques à chacun
mais qui sont extrêmement concomitantes.
Comment se construit le discours ?
D'abord, tout à coup, on dit on se
puise, on se penche dans le temps long.
C'est-à-dire, on dit "Mais attention,
notre identité depuis la nuit des temps,
c'est comme si c'est comme ça." Alors,
le temps long, ça a un avantage, c'est
que ça permet de réécrire l'histoire.
Donc, on va dire cette terre nous a été
donnée par Dieu. D'ailleurs, Moïse est
arrivé avec le titre de propriété. Donc,
tu vois le à quoi sert le talon ? Bon,
chez les hindouistes, c'est euh l'Inde
était hindouiste avant que les musulmans
n'arrivent. Or, les musulmans ont occupé
le pouvoir en Inde pendant plus de 7
siècles. Donc leur argumentaire, c'est
de dire c'était une occupation
intolérable et donc elle n'a pas lieu
d'être.
Troisème remarque, c'est la construction
d'un discours victimaire, c'est-à-dire
le chez les hindouistes par exemple.
Donc dans cette affirmation de
l'identité
hindouiste, il y a ce qu'on appelle
l'indouva. Donc ce ce philosophie posée
par Zavarcar, il va consister à dire
l'occupation par les musulmans du
sous-continent ont a généré une comment
dire un génocide de l'ordre de 100
millions de personnes. 100 millions de
personnes. Bon c'est à l'échelle de
l'INE d'accord mais enfin il reste que
c'est quand même un gros un gros
massacre. Alors personne n'a jamais
validé ses chiffres sur le plan
scientifique mais à force d'être répété
il deviennent un argumentaire important
si tu veux de la de la persécution. par
l'autre et donc du malheur que du pays.
Ensuite euh l'idée donc de la vengeance,
il faut se venger puisqu'on a été
victime et donc l'idée de l'expulsion,
le génocide, l'épuration ethnique voilà
ou alors forme soft les lois pour brider
le la place que le l'autre occupe sur
ton territoire.
Par exemple là en Birmanie, les
dernières lois votées par les par le les
moines avec l'appui des moines radicaux
et l'armée, c'est une loi qui limite le
nombre d'enfants par femme dans les
familles musulmanes par exemple.
J'ouvre une petite parenthèse. Le
Birmanions
qui légitime de journalistes en prison.
Bah oui, il y a eu erreur sur la
personne quoi. Il y a des castings qui
se trompent hein. C'est pas
Vas-y continue.
Non mais je veux dire oui on découvre
que la personne n'est pas ce qu'on
imaginait donc on va un peu vite avec
les les trucs de la P1 quand même avec
les prix Nobel de la P1. Il faut quand
même se rendre compte que c'est pas ça
garantit pas le reste de la vie de la
personne. Il y en a qui s'y tiennent et
puis il y en a d'autres qui qui pouir.
Une vie courte et mourir en héros ou une
vie longue et finir comme le diable.
Je sais pas, difficile à dire. C'est
difficile à dire le
Je termine juste un point qui est
intéressant pour les auditeurs. Parmi
les campagnes les plus ridicules que
j'ai vu et en tout cas les plus
odieuses, en Inde, il y a une campagne
qui s'appelle le Love Jihad,
c'est-à-dire ils accusent des jeunes
musulmans d'être mandatés pour séduire
des jeunes filles hindouistes pour
ensuite les convertir
avec le mariage et cetera. Et donc ils
ont adopté une loi qui autorise les
parents à faire annuler le mariage s'ils
estiment que leur fille a été manipulée.
Ça rend le divorce moins onéreux que
chez nous. C'est déjà moins un avantage.
Donc c'est pour dire que jusqu'où on va
si tu veux dans la forme légale de la du
rejet de l'autre. Accessoirement les les
musulmans en Inde c'est quand même 140
millions de personnes. Donc c'est pas
une petite minorité. Donc on est dans
cette montée de cette espèce de
radicalisme qui est une espèce
d'idéologie totalitaire. Leur
caractéristique à toutes ces idéologies,
c'est le comment dire la manière de
régimenter la vie quotidienne de chaque
individu.
C'est vraiment l'idée si vous voulez
être un véritable bon moyen, un bon
musulman, un bon juif, un bon chrétien
et cetera, tout était dicté par la loi
religieuse.
C'est c'est quoi l'énergie de cette
montée en puissance de ce radicalisme ?
C'est la crise financière, c'est la
perte de valeur, c'est un repli
identitaire, c'est l'accaparement des
terres, c'est quoi ? Il y a beaucoup de
choses. C'est vrai, c'est difficile d'en
donner une explication simple. Ce qui
est sûr, c'est que le retour identitaire
se [grognement] fait en particulier sur
une base religieuse. Il faut reconnaître
que
c'est plus facile,
hein.
C'est plus facile.
Oui, c'est plus facile. Mais en même
temps, bon, qu'est-ce qu'on offre en
plus dans la mondialisation ? Si c'est
une société du fun, enjoy sexe, il y a
beaucoup de sociétés dans laquelle ça
marche pour un certain nombre de
personnes, ça marche pas pour d'autres.
Le par exemple dans le l'affaire d'Abou
Graïb, c'est très intéressant quand ils
ont passé ces photos de mecs torturés,
foutu à poil, couvert de merde avec des
chiens qui leur voyaient dessus. C'est
déguisé en sapin de Noël,
pardon.
Déguisé en sapin de Noël.
Et donc ces types étaient minus devant
des soldats féminins américains. Dans
l'ensemble du monde arabe, ça a été
considéré comme une espèce de
d'indessence. C'était la forme suprême
de l'humiliation pour les hommes. Mais
la dessence c'est aussi une valeur he je
veux dire c'est pas parce que chez les
Américains, on considère que pour une
une vedette pour réussir de montrer son
cul que dans le reste de la planète
quand on humilie quelqu'un en le mettant
nu c'est une forme de l'indessence et
l'indesscence c'est aussi un respect
vis-à-vis de l'autre quoi. Bon enfin la
desessence c'est un respect vis-àis de
l'autre. Donc l'idée que ce choc des
cultures, tu vois, se passe puisse
hurtiquer si tu veux dans civilisation
euh il y a pas de balance à faire en
disant nous on est le bien et puis eux
s'ils sont bloqués. Donc euh ça c'est
quand même quelque chose dont on mesure
pas le dont on mesure pas le la vacuité.
Qu'est-ce qu'on a à offrir ? Gagnez du
pognon donc de préférence entrer dans la
banque. Si vous voulez réussir dans la
chanson, de préférence à poil et cetera
et cetera. Bon écoute, c'est pas c'est
pas une société qui porte des valeurs
des valeurs élevées. Donc même dans ces
sociétés là, il y a une espèce de retour
du religieux avec une espèce de mystique
si tu veux qui se crée avec des sectes,
avec des tas de saloperies comme ça. On
est obligé de constater le phénomène. On
est obligé de le constater quand tu as
tout à coup un type qui se qui se
sacrifie
comme ça s'est fait lors de la prise
d'otage avec le le colonel
français de gendarmerie là. Merde, j'ai
oublié son nom.
[grognement]
Euh, tu te rend bien compte qu'on a
besoin de héros, c'est-à-dire d'un seul
coup, on se rend compte que un type peut
avoir des systèmes de valeur qui
l'amènent à se à sacrifier sa vie.
Il faut retrouver son nom. Ouais. On
demande à la communauté de faire en
direct le gendarme
pardon. Pardon. Donc, on est sur quelque
chose où on est quand même une société
qui véhicule du vide.
On peut toujours dire les droits de
l'homme et cetera et cetera, mais par
exemple
les congrès du les avancées du LGBT
amène à des renversements
extraordinaires de système de valeur
quand on vit dans une société
différente. C'est-à-dire que tout à
coup, on va expliquer aux autres que
s'ils appliquent pas les règles pour les
LGBT, c'est queils sont des sociétés euh
oppressives.
Bon, on va pas d'un seul coup leur faire
en 6 mois parce que c'est nous qui le
diffusons. Parce que nous, on a mis de
siècles à accepter.
En plus, il y a des sociétés dans
lesquelles on comprend pas pourquoi il
nous explique que l'homosexualité
doit pas être réprimée alors qu'elle est
pratiquée.
Quand on voit Macron
organiser une un concert
en couleur à l'Élysée, comment on peut
être perçu dans ces
le quel concert ?
Le fait de la musique.
Ouais. Non, j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas
suivi. Ça m'a pas ça m'a pas intéressé.
Non, il y a des sujets sur lesquels j'ai
rien à dire.
[grognement]
Arnaud Beltran.
Ah, Arna Bertran. Voilà, exactement.
Donc, on voit on voit combien
effectivement cette société a besoin de
changer de temps en temps d'idole quoi.
Ça peut pas être uniquement de savoir
combien de followers on a sur
sur Facebook quand on est une vedette
qui va tout à coup expliquer son
programme du matin au soir.
Pour combattre cette radicalisation
grandissante des préconisations ou c'est
juste un constat ?
Je sais pas. Moi, je suis pour le moment
plutôt dans le constat.
Bon, évidemment, ma préoccupation, c'est
quand même le fait de voir tout à coup
cette ébullition dans un certain nombre
d'espacces religieux qui prennent
évidemment des caractéristiques
particulièrement violentes. Donc, ce qui
éidemment m'intéresse à cause de de mon
passé, c'est les formes violentes de
cette radicalisation. Faut penser que
par exemple au Myanmar, on est à entre
700 et 900000 réfugiés quand même. Donc,
c'est pas négligeable. C'est à la limite
plus que ce qui a été fait dans
laoslavie dans le même lapse de temps.
Donc cette cette diffusion de ce
radicalisme est évidemment un sujet de
préoccupation. Ça veut dire que ça
change la nature des conflits parce que
si les le Myanmar ils expulsent les
musulmans roingia qui sont sur leur
territoire Birmanie. Non
en Birmanie le mienmar. Oui c'est la
Birmanie. Euh
quelle est la légitimité de la
communauté internationale à intervenir ?
On va dire c'est pas une guerre. Ouais,
c'est une épuration ethnique.
C'est pour des questions de pétrole.
Non, il y a ça aussi, mais c'est pas le
c'est pas la question de pétrole. C'est
surtout que on est en porte à fou.
C'estàd on dit s'il faut intervenir
contre pour soutenir les roying pourquoi
ne pas intervenir pour soutenir les
Palestiniens.
Donc faut faire attention. Je dire on
peut pas avancer tout à coup un
argumentaire qui risque de se retourner
parce qu'encore une fois la vie
internationale est pas une vie de
principe, c'est une vie de rapport de
force. Et donc on dit là c'est bien et
là c'est pas bien mais c'est parce qu'on
a la capacité à dire aux autres c'est
pas bien ce que vous faites mais fermer
sa gueule sur les autres. Donc on voit
bien que sur le cas des Reng, on peut
pas intervenir. De la même façon en
Inde, la plus grande démocratie du monde
où ils prennent des mesures
antimusulmanes, où il y a des faux
grands. Par exemple, la dernière des la
dernière des folies des des hindouistes
radicaux, c'est de dire maintenant, il
faut interdire le commerce de la vache.
Or, le commerce de la vache, il faut
savoir que l'Inde était le plus gros
exportateur de viande de bœuf dans le
monde, que ce commerce était tenu par
des musulmans et des chrétiens, c'estàd
des gens qui n'étaient pas touchés par
cet interdit. Mais maintenant, les
hindouistes radicaux veulent interdire
ce commerce. Et ça se traduit par le
fait que des mecs ont été lychés par des
militants arrivants, tu vois, du genre.
Donc on est dans une espèce de phase de
prénocide
mais tant que ça reste au niveau de
l'Inde, c'està dire que c'est même une
dizaine, une canine de personnes, on se
dit "Oui, mais c'est un pays d'un
milliard d'O." Donc on va être face à
des scénarios de conflit qui sont
extrêmement compliqués. En tout cas, la
communauté internationale n'aura pas
obligatoirement la légitimité à
intervenir pour pour se mêler de ce
genre de choses.
Ça veut dire quoi la communauté
internationale ? Mais la communauté
internationale, c'est ceux qui si tu
veux en gros qui sont responsables de la
démarrère guerres mondiales, hein. C'est
les États-Unis, la France, la le la
Russie, la Chine, euh la
Grande-Bretagne, sauf l'Allemagne, mais
qui maintenant est dans le 5 + 1 pour
l'Iran et qui donc prétendent d'avoir
hérité de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
qu'ils ont provoqué, qu'ils ont
mondialisé la le la philosophie, le
devoir de de
garantir la sécurité internationale.
Alors quand même, il faut que les
auditeurs comprennent que la
construction de l'eau nu telle qu'elle
se fait dans la charte de 48 est
construite non pas sur le principe du
consensus mais sur le principe du véau.
C'est-à-dire on a donné à cinq pays
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité le pouvoir de s'opposer à toute
décision de l'ONU sur le sujet qu' qui
les gêne. Ces cinq pays ont fait depuis
la seconde depuis 45 depuis la création
de l'ONU à peu près une cinquantaine de
conflits dans lesquels ils ont interdit
à la communauté internationale de se
mêler.
Par exemple, la guerre d'Algérie, la
France a toujours refusé que l'ONU s'en
mêle, le Vietnam et cetera, la rue,
l'Afghanistan et cetera. Donc, tu vois,
à chaque fois le vétoit que l'ONU était
paralysé par ça. C'est ça le principe de
fonctionnement de l'ONU.
Donc, on est aujourd'hui
quand on prend par exemple un embargo,
on le prend dans le cas où ça gêne le
moins de monde. C'est pas le cas dans
lequel c'est le plus dramatique. C'est
celui dans lequel les pays siègens au
conseil de sécurité n'y voit pas
d'inconvénient.
D'où la raison de l'absence totale
d'embargo sur l'Arabie Saoudite. Voilà.
Pogon, c'est ça ?
Oui. Le pognon, les affaires et cetera
et cetera. Donc le le principe de la du
droit international, c'est quand même en
gros c'est un principe à trou hein géré
par des des puissants et qui sont en
mesure de dire là là il faut
l'appliquer, là il faut pas l'appliquer.
Donc on est on est sur un un système qui
est fondamentalement unique et qui fait
que toute notre philosophie des droits
de l'homme comme on l'applique à double
usage, à double standard si tu veux
quand on parle des uns et quand on parle
des autres, tu peux imaginer qu'il y a
effectivement dans quelques pays de la
quelques coins de la planète des gens
qui disent qu'il y en a marre que les
occidentaux passent leur temps à donner
des leçons aux autres. rappelle-toi
quand même que quand on charte, on signe
la charte des Nations- Unies en 48,
les cinq pays signataires sont les
États-Unis qui sont un pays raciste avec
des des lois ségrégationnistes. C'est la
Russie de Staline, grande démocratie
s'il en est. C'est la France et la
Grande-Bretagne qui sont les deux plus
grandes puissances coloniales de la
planète. Et c'est la Chine de Thangai
Cheek. Donc tu vois la internationale,
c'est faites ce que je dis, faites pas
ce que je fais. [soupir][souffle coupé]
On arrive vers la fin. Est-ce que
d'autres choses à aborder ?
Non, je
Alors, un conseil pour les jeunes
générations,
je reprendrai bien le slogan
indignez-vous, mais malheureusement, je
suis pas sûr que ça fasse beaucoup
bouger les chemil blic, quoi. Mais il
faut le faire de toute façon, c'est
évident. Il faut absolument euh que les
jeunes générations ne pensent pas que
tout est définitivement figé. Il y a une
part de comment dire d'initiative de
capacité à à changer le monde qui qui le
fait de la jeunesse. Euh prends le
l'exemple de la du réchauffement de la
planète.
On se rend bien compte que ce qui heurte
toute véritable politique, c'est la
comment dire la tradition des habitudes.
C'est-à-dire que faudrait changer
beaucoup des des modes de fonctionnement
quotidien de nos pratiques, de nos modes
de circulation avec des véhicules diesel
et cetera. Et on voit bien que tu vois,
c'est une espèce de viscosité très très
grande. Donc
peut-être notre système éducatif.
Oui, mais c'est pas chez les jeunes
qu'on va rencontrer le plus de
difficultés. C'est plutôt effectivement
chez une société installée qui
effectivement voit beaucoup de
difficultés l'idée de changer de mode de
de communication de vie et cetera. Moi
j'étais toujours j'ai toujours en tête
ce souvenir qui était qui a suivi M68 où
c'était GB qui dessinait l'an 01. Il
disait "On arrête tout et on réfléchit,
c'est pas triste." Et c'était une espèce
de société utopique dans lesquelles on
pensait pour la première fois à
consommer autrement.
Et donc il y avait l'idée du vélo, du
solaire et cetera et cetera. Et c'était
en 68. Ça veut dire que depuis plus de
50 ans ces idées étaient tangèr mais
elles étaient considérées comme
utopiques à l'époque. Bon l'utopie, elle
ne prend que s'il y a des jeunes qui se
mobilisent pour que cette utopie ne se
ne cesse pas. Maintenant, faut bien
penser aussi que chez les jeunes, il y a
aussi des salafistes radicaux, hein.
C'est des gens qui pensent que l'utopie,
ça n'est pas obligatoirement celle qu'on
imagine nous, que c'est aussi cette
utopie religieuse qui va tout à coup
régler tous les problèmes de la planète
parce que on a trouvé la clé secrète qui
une fois appliquée à tout le monde, de
préférence à coup de décapitation et de
viol résoudre tous les problèmes de la
planète. Et on a cette ce comportement
chez tous les radicaux religieux. Donc
malheureusement, il faut faire gaffe à
l'utopie qu'on est en train de
manipuler.
Alors, pour résumer trivialement, c'est
mobilisez-vous. Ouais, mobilisez-vous
mais attention pas sur n'importe quoi et
surtout laissez tomber toute idéologie
qui vous donne une explication complète
de la planète. Il y a que dans les
contradiction qu'on progresse.
Pierre Connaissa, merci.
Merci à vous.